objectif france est un mouvement nouveau
rafik smati à une colonne vertébrale
idéologique de droite qui est forte et
qui en même temps est capable de porter
des projets aux nouveaux comme
l'écologie par exemple où l'intelligence
artificielle objectif france ce
mouvement politique ne vous dit peut
être rien pourtant il existe depuis 2014
à sa tête rafik smati chefs
d'entreprises français de 41 ans
il réunissait mardi soir à versailles
les adhérents et les curieux pour le
lancement du mouvement dans les yvelines
quel est notre objectif la france dira
qu' on est un mouvement politique on est
on a envie de tourner la page de 30 ans
de lâcheté de renoncement de d'abandon
idéologique nous nous sommes un
mouvement de nouvelle génération qui
rassemblant plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes en france qui
commence à voir un ancrage territorial
fort l'envi de donner un nouveau souffle
au visage politique français est un
point fondamental d'objectifs france le
mouvement libéral-conservateur cherche à
associer des valeurs modernes et
écologiques
nous parlons de ce monde en mutation de
cette de ce tsunami technologique qui
est devant nous qui est comparable à une
seconde renaissance et qui va tout
redéfinir notre rapport à l'économie
notre rapport au travail
notre rapport à la santé notre rapport
au vivant et nous voulons projeter la
france dans ce monde parce que si nous
ne montons pas dans ce train là eh bien
il va y avoir un très grand nombre de
naufrages est clairement en opposition
avec le président macron et son
mouvement en marche
rafik smati évoque son souhait de
rassembler la droite
notre objectif n'est pas de créer un
petit mouvement qui se situera à la
périphérie du système et qui fera trois
ou quatre pour cent donc nous ferons ce
qu'il faut pour être au centre de la
recomposition de la droite
le mouvement compte aujourd'hui près de
33 mille adhérents dans toute la france
et 350 dans les yvelines un département
qui reste encore à convaincre